YURI GRINSHTEYN: Hi,
everyone out in YouTube land.
Thank you so much
for joining us today.
As always, I am Yuri
Grinshteyn, your host.
And I'm incredibly excited today
because for the first time,
we have guests in the studio.
We have Shirlin and
Christoph from Elastic.
Please introduce yourselves.
SHIRLIN YIU: Sure.
Thanks, Yuri.
Hi, my name is Shirlin Yiu.
And I'm from Elastic.
I'm on the business
development team.
So very happy to be here today.
Thanks for having us.
CHRISTOPHER WURM: Hi, guys.
I'm Christopher.
I'm a principal
solution architect.
So I work with all of
the users and customers
that we have in the Bay Area.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Awesome.
I am really excited.
Thank you so much for taking
the time to join us today.
I really appreciate it.
I imagine a lot of
folks on the line
have probably heard of Elastic.
And they know what you all do.
But I think they would also
like to hear from you as well.
So Shirlin, can you tell
us a bit about Elastic?
SHIRLIN YIU: Absolutely.
So as Yuri said, for those
who are not familiar with us,
here's a little bit
of history of Elastic.
So it all started back in
2010 when our COO, Shay Banon,
he was working in London.
And he wanted to create a recipe
search engine for his wife.
Now at that point in time, there
wasn't any great open source
text search engine out there.
So what'd he do?
He was like, I'm going to
create my own, which he decided
to call it Elasticsearch,
made it open source,
and put on GitHub.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
That's brilliant.
SHIRLIN YIU: Yeah, and then
the community picked it up.
People really liked it.
And at the very beginning,
people mostly use it for search
[? text ?] [? raster ?] purpose.
So the early adopters would
be like, Wikipedia, Facebook,
GitHub, and just a search
engine for a bunch of websites.
And then sooner or later, people
realized that hey, you know,
Elasticsearch has more
than just text search.
You can use it for searching
through machine data for lots
of metrics.
I mean, it makes sense because
Elasticsearch is really fast.
It scales really well.
And it has real
time read and write.
So it becomes more
and more popular.
And then we start
building tools around it.
So say, for example, there
is Logstash for ingestion,
and there's Kibana
for visualization.
And that gives us the
acronym of ELK, ELK Stack.
[INAUDIBLE] ELK, Elasticsearch,
Logstash, and Kibana.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: OK, very cool.
SHIRLIN YIU:
Straightforward, yep.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: So
you just said something
that's really interesting.
You said that the company
started when your founder put
some code on GitHub.
Obviously, here
at Google, we are
very much committed to
an open source philosophy
and supporting the
open source community.
Is Elastic still open search--
or, sorry-- open source?
Or is your code
still open source?
SHIRLIN YIU: Absolutely.
So we are, at the
core, open source.
But we also built
and developed a bunch
of other commercial
functionalities around it so
that to assist the users
in the community out there.
For example, there is
security monitoring, alerting,
and the machine learning.
And Christoph will
be showing off
a bit of those in a few seconds.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Awesome.
That's really cool.
I'm actually excited
to hear that.
And obviously, ELK is something
that I hear about a lot.
I've worked with a bunch of
customers that use Elastic.
I've always heard good
things about it, something
that I think everyone I've
ever talked to has always
said good things about it.
So I'm excited to
have you all here.
SHIRLIN YIU: That's great.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Thank you
so much for doing this.
So maybe at this point, it
might make sense for Christoph
to take us one level down.
Show us how to use Elastic,
what it can do for folks.
And I think one of
the things, obviously,
that I'm interested in is
how can folks that are in GCP
use it?
CHRISTOPHER WURM:
Yeah, yeah, for sure.
Do you want to show my screen?
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Yeah.
CHRISTOPHER WURM: Let's do that.
Great.
So here we have the Google
Cloud Platform Launcher,
which most of you
will be familiar with.
And what you can do is--
we have several
ways of deployment.
You can, of course, just
download the software.
It's open source to all.
You can just download it and
run it on just GCP instances.
But what we also
offer is we also offer
a fully managed service,
a hosted service, where
we run the software for you.
And we're in Google Launcher.
So what you can do is you
can search for, we call it,
Elastic Cloud.
So If you search for that
here, it's going to appear.
And then if you
click on the link,
there's some information here.
And then if you click on the
link, you get the website.
And the way it
looks is like this.
So here, basically, in this UI,
you specify the cluster size.
So you have this
nice slider here.
We can just determine the
size of cluster you want.
You can choose the GCP region
that you want to be in.
We have four regions available.
You can also choose how many
availabilities [INAUDIBLE]
have depending on the mission
criticality of the cluster.
You can choose
things like versions
and various other settings.
But then at the end of the
day, you simply click Create.
And within a few minutes,
we're going to spin up
a new cluster for you.
And then we're going to
give you the UL that you
can use to log in and just do
everything that you want to do.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: So you
actually just showed
something really interesting.
I've obviously seen
a lot of solutions
that are available on
the Cloud Launcher.
But most of them, when you
hit that button, what it does
is basically deploys stuff
on Compute Engine, right?
So it goes out there and
installs the software.
And then you're interacting
with it using your--
typically, maybe your private
IPs or your public IPs.
It's basically an
installer, whereas--
well, you've just
shown us is actually
a fully managed service
that just happens
to use GCP as the back end.
CHRISTOPHER WURM: Correct.
Correct, yeah.
And the back end
[AUDIO OUT] of course, we
also have GCP instances.
But it's GCP instances
that we manage.
And we just deploy our users'
and customers' clusters on it
and then just manage it from
our site and give you the API
endpoint to use.
So I think it's just much
more managed and much easier
to use that way.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Very cool.
All right, so now that we
have a good idea of how
do get started,
show us what you can
do once you have the cluster.
CHRISTOPHER WURM:
Yeah, yeah, of course.
So once you have
the cluster set up,
one of the things that you
have to do is to get the data.
I'm not going to show that here.
But it's relatively
simple to do.
We integrate with a number
of services and GCP as well.
So I think the [? commands ?]
will be something like the data
flow or [INAUDIBLE] that
we can integrate with
to receive the data and then
store it in Elasticsearch,
the data store.
And then on top of that, we
have what you see here, which
is Kibana, the user interface.
And there's really several
things that you can do here.
One of the things I'm showing
right here-- so one thing
that you can do is you can
just look at your raw data.
So here we have some web
logs that we've gathered from
our own website, elastic.co,
about six weeks' worth of log
data from early 2017.
And what we can see here is
just the request over time
as well as the
individual requests.
And what we could do is we could
drill down into each of them.
What I want to show here
is some of the things
that you can search and filter.
So for example, we have
a search bar up here.
And I can search for,
for example, a city.
And we get all of the
requests from the city.
We've enriched the data
as it was coming in.
We just got IP addresses.
But then you can
match the IP address
to the city and the
country and the continent
that it's coming from.
And we did that here before
we persisted the data.
And so here, for the
[? dom ?] on just Paris.
And so we can see
all of the requests
that we've gotten from Paris.
What we could do is we could
further filter down on,
for example, a specific UL.
Now we see all of the
requests from Paris
that we're looking
at this blog post.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: One
of things I'm actually
impressed with already is
just this is pretty quick.
You started out with something
like 14 million rows.
You just got it down to 14 hits.
I mean, it was fast.
CHRISTOPHER WURM: Yeah, yeah.
We try.
We build a lot of
data structures
in the background to
make it fast-- indexers.
And then we just take
advantage of multiple levels
of caching to make sure that
especially heavily access
data is extremely fast.
As Shirlin said, the reason to
use Elasticsearch for something
is if you need near real-time
access to your data,
if you need to write
huge volumes of data
very quickly, but also if you
need to access it very quickly.
If you have something like
web logs or your metrics
or if you're doing
website search,
then fast access to
data is essential.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: So let
me ask you a question.
And you can tell me if you think
that this answer is perhaps
too complex to address here.
Obviously, if you're
running on GCP,
your logging is being
generated by Stackdriver.
Is there a simple mechanism
to get all those logs
into Elasticsearch?
CHRISTOPHER WURM:
Yeah, there is.
So Stackdriver integrates
with Google Pub/Sub.
And then Google Pub/Sub
can feed into Elastic.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Very cool.
So exporting logs to
Pub/Sub is something
that lots of customers do.
Typically, they
will often, then,
take them into something
like BigQuery from there.
But sending them to
Elastic for the analysis
that you've just shown us
is, I think, really useful.
And it seems like it's
pretty easy to do.
All right, so let's continue.
CHRISTOPHER WURM:
Yeah, of course.
So one more thing that
we might want to do
is we might want to
look at a specific user
and just look at what
this user has been doing.
So let's just pick--
I always love doing live demos.
So let's just pick a random
IP address from here.
And let's see if it works.
So if we--
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Living on the edge.
CHRISTOPHER WURM: Absolutely.
SHIRLIN YIU:
[? And here's ?] [INAUDIBLE]..
CHRISTOPHER WURM: So if
we take this one request,
what one can do is let's look
at the called the Surrounding
Documents.
Let's filtered on
just this IP address.
And then what we can see is
we can see this IP address has
requested a certain blog post.
And if we go further back, we
can see that right before that
it was [? the ?]
[? Downloads ?] page.
So currently downloading
Elasticsearch.
Before that was on our product
page for Elasticsearch.
And before that, in our
generic product pace,
a normal customer user flow
that we can observe here.
You could imagine using this
for something like root cause
analysis, where you have some
kind of error message that
you're looking for, some
kind of exception that
you've [? seen a ?] [? lot ?]
so that some user has told you
about.
And you want to see
what happened exactly
before this error message, what
led up to this error message.
And this is the kind of view
where you would do that,
exploring the data.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Yep, absolutely.
Makes a lot of sense.
CHRISTOPHER WURM: Yeah.
Now exploring the raw data
is one way to look at it.
And then the other way that
you can look at your data
is to aggregate, to
look at the big picture.
And so what we can do is we
can build visualizations.
And then out of
these visualizations,
we can build dashboards.
And let's look at what
that looks like here.
So simple visualization
is always the pie chart.
Here we can see this pie chart
is showing the different HTTP
response codes that we
see in our web logs.
So the majority of
response codes are 200.
So everything's fine.
That's good.
But then we also have a sizable,
30%, of web logs that are 404.
So people or applications
trying to access
part of a website that we--
and this request failed.
And so we might want to explore
this a little bit further.
What kind of
requests were these?
Where are they coming from?
What IP addresses, what
URLs, what resources
did these people try to access?
And so for that, you
probably want a dashboard.
And here we have
such a dashboard.
It's showing a lot
of different things,
things like where our
requests coming from.
We have a map up here.
But also how many
requests do we have?
14 million.
And then various other
charts where we break things
down by response code,
by a number of unique IP
addresses, number of
visitors, by operating system,
by browser, and by their
resources, and the piece
that they're accessing.
And actually at the
bottom here, we also
have the raw recruits
in this dashboard,
we can both see
the visualizations,
[? where ?] we're aggregating.
But we can also see the raw
requests, the [INAUDIBLE]..
Now what I want
might want to do here
is because I saw quite
a number of 404 errors,
I might want to understand
better what led to these
and what these 404s even are.
So one thing I can do
is I can filter down
to just the 404 errors.
And I see an
interesting thing here,
where my number of
404 errors over time
were relatively constant
and relatively low,
and suddenly it spiked.
And that might be something
interesting to look into.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: And
that was really fast.
You were able to
fill the-- and then
it actually refreshed every
element in the dashboard
in what looked like to
be less than a second.
I mean, that is really
impressive performance.
CHRISTOPHER WURM:
Yeah, thank you.
Yeah, definitely.
I mean, this is what
you need, right?
This is what you
need when you're
doing some kind of root cause
analysis, some kind of data
exploration.
You're trying to find out what's
happening with your system
right now.
And so speed is key.
We can see all the
404 errors here.
We have a spike
in the 404 errors.
And that's something
interesting that I
want to dive deeper into.
And I could now do things
like look at the raw requests
and maybe filter down even more.
But there's one more thing
that I want to show here
and that is how we
do anomaly detection.
Anomaly detection, or we also
call it machine learning,
is one of the
commercial features
that we have for
enterprise users.
And so I just want to quickly
show what that looks like.
So for that, let's create one
of those anomaly detection
machining learning jobs.
So what I can do here
in this interface is--
YURI GRINSHTEYN: So
before you create it,
can you explain the
terminology here?
CHRISTOPHER WURM: Yeah.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: What is a
job in the Elastic ecosystem?
Because obviously, everyone
uses the term "jobs."
And everyone kind of attaches
a different meaning to it.
CHRISTOPHER WURM:
That's a good point.
Yeah, so a job in
that context is
when we do anomaly
detection, you usually
want to do some kind of
analysis on your historical data
that you have.
In this case, we already have
six weeks' worth of data.
So we want to analyze these
And now that is something
that we don't necessarily
want to do synchronously.
But it's something
that [AUDIO OUT]
it happened in the
background asynchronously.
So that's what's called a "job."
Now everything else
that we've seen so for,
every search that I've
done, the filtering, looking
at surrounding documents, the
dashboard, and the filtering
in the dashboard-- all of
that are synchronous requests.
Like if I've done
something-- and then I've
had to wait a little
bit for it to show up.
Now that works when I'm
doing the signal requests.
But when I'm doing something
like anomaly detection on six
weeks' worth of data, then
no matter how fast we are,
it's going to take some time.
And so that's why we
need to create job.
And then the job runs
in the background
to create these anomalies.
And that also just keeps running
as new data keeps coming in
and just keeps creating,
finding these anomalies.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: OK, cool.
Thank you.
It helps.
CHRISTOPHER WURM:
Yeah, no, sure.
Thanks for asking.
So here in this UI, we can
see how we create such a job.
What we've tried to
do is we've tried
to abstract away a lot
of the complexities
of anomaly detection.
Once, we tried internally,
[? as ?] somebody-- once,
the developers tried
internally to explain
to us how the anomaly
detection actually works,
the math behind it.
And well, I'm afraid I didn't
understand a lot of it.
But what we tried
to do is we tried
to abstract away all of the
little complexities of it
and just give our
users a nice UI.
And this was an API to use it
to make it usable for everybody.
Now in this case, I
have [? replica ?] data.
So what I want to
look at is maybe
I want to look at the number
of visitors on my website.
It's an important KPI for
every website to track that.
And so I can see this
from my web logs.
What I have to do is let's
look at the unique count,
the distinct count
of IP addresses.
And in a second here, we should
be seeing just the general
up and down that the
data like this shows us.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: And
again, while we're waiting,
can you explain
what [INAUDIBLE]----
I see that you can click on
the little [? i's ?] to get
an explanation of that
particular feature.
But what is a bucket span?
CHRISTOPHER WURM:
Good point, yeah.
So what we need to do is the
number of visitors has to be--
only makes sense in
a certain time frame.
How many visitors have
you had in one minute
or in five minutes
or in 20 minutes?
And so it kind of
controls-- the bucket span
controls the granularity
of the analysis.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Got it.
OK, that makes sense.
CHRISTOPHER WURM:
Yeah, so here we're
looking at 15-minutes
bucket spans.
Now here we can see
the data aggregators.
And we can already visually
see that there is probably
some kind of anomaly here in
the latter half of the data.
Now, if we had a dashboard
or visualization that
was showing exactly
this and that,
this is something that we
would probably see visually.
But the whole point is,
of anomaly detection,
especially this kind of
automated anomaly detection,
is to not actually
have to have this, to
not actually have somebody
looking at these dashboards
and visualizations all the time.
So the goal of this job
is to basically find
this anomaly as well as
any other anomalies that
might exist in here that
we don't see visually.
Now I don't need to
do anything else.
I'm just going to give it a
name and then create the job.
And because this is a
relatively simple job,
I'm just looking at the
number of visitors over time.
It's just one metric.
It should be relatively quick.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Oh, wow.
And you actually watch
it work in real-time.
It's actually showing you the
data it's already analyzed.
CHRISTOPHER WURM: Yeah, yeah.
It shows you how it builds
the model in real-time
and how it finds the anomalies.
And so it seems that it has
actually found the anomaly
that we were looking for.
One thing that we could
do is we could just
continue running this job.
Any new data that comes in
is compared against the model
that we built in the background.
And then any new anomalies being
found, we could do something,
like get an email
alert of some sort.
But let's look at
the results here.
So if we look at
the results, let's
look at the very beginning.
It's kind of interesting
to look at how
this anomaly detection works.
So if we can see here, the
first few days of data, we
didn't really get a good read.
The model, the shaded
area and background,
is relatively imprecise.
It just has an upper
and lower bound.
But then as we kind of go
further into the future,
we can see how the model
tracks the data pretty well.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: And
I mean, generally,
that's one of the
expectations you'll
have with machine learning.
[INAUDIBLE] the more data you
have, the more analysis you do,
the more precise your
results are going to be,
the better the
trained the model is.
And over time, your results
get better and better.
So it makes a lot of sense.
CHRISTOPHER WURM: Yeah.
And so we can see here that it
has finally found the normally
that we were looking for.
This is real data.
So this actually happened
to us on-- this looks
like a Monday morning.
We had our usual spike in
visitors as people come to work
and they start working.
And they're using Elastic.
So they're looking at the
website for different things.
And then we suddenly
had a big drop
down in our number
of visitors here.
We can see this visually.
But we can also
look into the table
down here, where we can see
that we were expecting--
the typical number of
visitors during this time
was about 1,450--
[INAUDIBLE] 1,450 visitors.
But we actually only
had 86 in this time.
So that is 17 times lower
than what we were expecting.
So it's a very big anomaly.
And that's why we mark it red.
And we give it a
very high score.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: So
am I going to spoil it
by asking you whether
you actually-- can
use this to know what happened?
Or do you know what
happened in retrospect?
CHRISTOPHER WURM: Here actually,
we do know what happened.
What we did is we have
a content management
system behind our website,
like everybody else.
And every once in a
while, we make a change.
And usually the
change is no problem.
Nothing bad happens.
But sometimes we
make a change that
doesn't work out really well.
So we made a change that
just broke a bunch of links
on our website.
And so a bunch of people that
tried to access [? things ?]
didn't work.
But we rolled it
back fairly quickly.
So it went back up.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: And
you can actually tell.
If you look at the data, I
mean, it went right back up.
So whoever was on call that
day was able to react really
quickly and figure it out.
CHRISTOPHER WURM: Yeah.
Yeah, and that's the
value of it, right?
It tells you really
quickly that something bad
is happening, something that you
might otherwise or even maybe
have missed.
If you have looked at the
data in any other way--
and then you can react
to it really quickly.
And that goes back to
a point about speed,
where you want to be fast.
We are the tool for accessing
any kind of data really
quickly, especially
the ones that
real-time autogenerate data,
things like machine data.
And yeah, it's different
ways that-- things
that you can do with it, search
it, filter it, aggregate it,
autoanomaly detection on it.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: Awesome.
Very cool.
Well, thank you so
much for that demo.
That was really informative.
I hope folks on the
line learned as well.
Yeah, if you wanted
to tell people
like what they should do next,
what would you recommend?
CHRISTOPHER WURM:
Oh, yeah, for sure.
So yeah, if you
want to use Elastic,
I think the easiest
way to get started
with it is to actually use
the Google Cloud Launcher that
was I showing earlier.
I think everybody
probably already
has a Google Cloud Account.
So just go in there.
Just search for Elastic Cloud.
And spin up maybe a
really small instance just
to get started with.
Get some data in maybe
from Stackdriver.
And yeah, then see what you get.
And see what you can do with it.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Yeah, very cool.
And I think that was the second
half of what I was going to say
is it's really easy
to get started, right?
Go to the launcher.
Sign up.
And get it rolling.
And then from there,
the easiest way
to get data into it,
which is obviously
what you need for an
analytics tool like this
to be useful, is yeah,
start up the Stackdriver
integration, right?
Just start getting logs from
GCP flowing via Pub/Sub.
And then go into Elastic.
And then you can get the stuff
really easily really quickly.
Awesome.
Say, thank you both so
much for being here today.
We're, as always,
really appreciative.
Thank you for your time.
Thanks for coming in,
teaching us about Elastic.
To everyone out there,
thank you so much for taking
the time to tune in.
We really appreciate
it as always.
Like, rate, subscribe, right?
That's what the kids on
YouTube say these days.
CHRISTOPHER WURM: [INAUDIBLE].
SHIRLIN YIU: Lots of likes.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
Yeah, that's right.
Lots of likes.
And we'll be back
on Thursday morning
with another customer story.
And we've got lots more
exciting stuff for you
for the rest of the month and
hopefully the rest of the year.
So thank you so much.
Thanks again to
Elastic for being here.
Thanks for bringing us stickers.
SHIRLIN YIU: Well, thank you.
YURI GRINSHTEYN: We've got
a whole pile of stickers
on the table.
We really appreciate it.
SHIRLIN YIU: Showcase that.
CHRISTOPHER WURM: Thanks, Yuri.
Thanks for having us.
SHIRLIN YIU: Thanks
for having us.
Thanks, everyone.
YURI GRINSHTEYN:
It's a pleasure.
All right, folks.
Have a great day.
CHRISTOPHER WURM: Bye bye.
SHIRLIN YIU: Bye.